welcome back to true news stru than ever
what do you want to show me first my
penis
[Music]
Wow what a crazy fight guys that was a
draw what's your opinion on beeping
things that annoys the [__] out of me
yeah it really annoys doesn't but you
want its kids going around school
they're [__] an effort and blind in
this all kids are saying nowadays it's
like is the new for a lot of these
things you understand what I mean by
love yeah I know you gonna beat that out
because we want to get magnetized but
don't do it so just put it no this is
gonna sound crazy but I have been
texting back and forth with faze banks I
want to fight him
just know that face banks versus Jake
Paul there's a very high possibility is
this exciting for you there's more real
beef in this one than any of the other
fights that we've seen so far with like
with Logan and JJ was just purely
competition they want to be number war
Jake Paul used to fill Elissa whose face
bunks is current girlfriend up with this
seaman right what was sort of like Annie
at a serene just saying no no nose penis
as a now he wants to prove he's better
than him in every way by beating him in
a boxing ring face bunks has responded
on Twitter saying where is it dead beef
or do you want me the fact that he's
asking his audience is a dead beef is he
looking for a way out there's you like
the hub yes probably dead before and it
you don't really fancy that yeah I think
the best thing is just imagine in this
from Alyssa's point of view I she's
ringside and her ex-boyfriend and
current boyfriend go head-to-head what
if Jake starts within the fight and she
starts getting a bit aroused that's a
really unusual thing isn't it no she
might just start tweaking her little
nipples and being like actually you know
what it is
she take him to France still still fancy
that still still won a bit because the
thing is I've seen women be interview
before after MMA fighters being fighting
about and they've admitted like when my
boyfriend went in there got smashed I
didn't fancy him anymore after that
if he starts winning what if she starts
fighting him more attractive we all know
that that's what everyone's thinking are
you fantasizing about that ex-girlfriend
of his nah right just to be absolutely
clear do you want to fight Jake Paul no
how many girls are on the line in this
imaginary five five five and three
camels just in the way that we used to
trade women you've considered this for
waiting
and now on true use into the mind of
Kanye West Drake hold trying to threaten
me so trick if anything happens to me or
anyone from my family you were the first
suspect so cut the tough talk he's
running around like he's to be texting
people I know like it's cool I'm the guy
with the pink polo that made the way for
him I'm your oxygen wow that is such a
statement you send emojis you will say
this [__] to me but won't say none of
this [__] the J Prince I navigated these
waters before you that's why you could
be you this is for no one's
entertainment nobody's scared of
anything
nobody's scared of anything for God's me
I think he corrects it and says nobody's
scared of anything but God right didn't
delete the previous three [__] I'm on a
roll here these tweets are not emotional
the [__] look at perhaps I should
have been more like water to do the
Drake claims he went help Kenya with his
album did so then all of a sudden Kenya
feeds all the info that he has on Drake
to push her push I used that on Drake
after cut off the drinks to nothing but
be good to Kanye see him
I think Kanye has played a bad hand and
he's trying to get out of it by giving
all of this positive vibe [__] and it's
like well yeah but truth be told you
were a little bit jealous of Drake you
tried to outmaneuver him and put him in
a bad space and Drake's just not having
it now I think drink just plays the game
well generally I think Kenya's too
erratic in into emotional that you get
to play this smart is what Drake has
Drake is a lot colder because candy has
got a feminine sight or one way he's
quite cutty quite a much jealous quite
[__] Drake trusted him as a man to not
[__] him over when it comes to the music
and he's done that
so now Drake's treating him like a man
all of these tweets as a sign of fear
from consciousness I think it's quite
he's frightened to Drake a while because
Drake's got some bosses around him who
are behind the scenes who would take
care of things for him they're awesome
like legit gangsters who are behind him
who will [__] take your [__] head
off you know I mean what as no it's the
art form no it's
competition but the morons who are
behind them don't get the game and what
they're trying to do is prove their
loyalty to this rapper by saying I'll
[__] do for you I'll do them for you
and really it doesn't need that team
start to make this out the other day
it's a guy who allegedly beats his
girlfriend during playing fortnight
whilst his room his name is mr. dead
mother dead mom let's just see it get
your reaction I just wanna see what you
think it's amazing already the fact that
they have in a domestic in the middle of
his live streaming yeah yeah neither of
them have got much respect for each
other [__] that he is talking bucket her
that way and she's having a go at him I
think it's okay to say that everyone has
arguments where people raise their voice
but it's when you're in public and
you're doing it like making a sure of
yourself
yeah you're instantly if you haven't got
enough respect for each other not to
embarrass each other in public then
you've got a [__] relationship yeah you
have to
she's come in to the room yeah and she's
trying to get him off it and he said
[__] off you dog hmm you don't clear the
[__] bills that's true but they only
knew or laaser Dogville
that's a real bad word but even if she
doesn't pay the bills this - the
relationship here there's a baby
involved as a kid involved so she's
pregnant and I can hear a baby in the
background I want to assume anything
obviously if she's pregnant then maybe
she can't pay the bills because she
needs to be on maternity leave or
whatever see how you really read things
yeah but you can't always relationships
like traditional relationships very
often the woman won't pay the bills
because she's making the sacrifice or
having a baby or whatever
[Music]
he's definitely at Nura
he's more Delbert he's definitely even
batteries grabbing her or something
there's still somebody saw his hands on
a lily there's no way you scream like
that
it is a pregnant woman who's in a
relationship and she's frustrated then
they clearly like you said had a
dysfunctional relationship neither of
them are doing something right but she's
clearly the one who needs more
protection in this because she's not
physically powerful in the way that he
is she's not got the financial security
but I find it strange though why someone
would dictate to someone else whether or
not they can play on a computer game or
not I mean that to me seems weird you
say that a lot in relationships these
days in 2018 yeah like men spending too
much time on a computer game really
seems too great on women it seems to be
like an actual issue in a lot of
relationships I think the thing that men
need to get across in their mind some
name system the minute you step that
lion over is in your hand
it doesn't matter everything else
becomes irrelevant instantly because
you've done something that's really
really really bad and let's be honest in
the eyes of the law they're always gonna
side on the side of the woman so you
have to be extra clean when you're a man
because a woman can say whatever the
hell she wants the minute you [__]
snap as a man like you're [__] it's
you and I mean that really sounds bad
the kids as well because yeah kitchen
not witness now whatever this girl this
woman is this guy is a [__] con
doesn't he it's so much about our video
show so much about him yeah and nobody
is 100% barred and no one's 1% good but
he's a con love sir
right moving on hey ksi and edgy took
their beef offline good yeah apparently
ki is keeping it keeping it low-key I
mean it was all a little bit of fun on
the disk trucks some of it went a bit
too far
yeah good they're just cornerstone move
on from diss tracks be real creative you
say that what there are there are some
districts they'll be released is its
district season yeah
as it as happens when it gets cold and
our cameraman someone sent for us why
would you send for carnival Pete I don't
get that I understand it colleague Lee I
I think he's I think he underestimated
him I think he looked at Connie went
that's easy I could smash that what do
you see when you look at con that me
easy um I think people underestimate
Kahn because he looks a bit yeah you
know I mean okay Kahn you can you come
and show your face so people get the
reference yeah people I look people look
at Khan and they think what the [__] is
that
do you know me they look at this little
nut yeah that thing yeah a little fun
stuff yeah and they just think what the
[__] hell is this right okay and one
of the people who thought that was Joel
or who featured on the Deji destruct to
ksi
he's Mir to destroy a con ah yes
who's that was a big shock he's really
stretched out this 15 minutes of fame
hasn't he
well it's Madison Walter he's wearing a
jacket still why cuz he don't know who
he is unless he's got the checkered odd
good point what's he said he said lower
that lower dat ting he means because
there's some music in the background
he's not talking about like her he's not
gonna cry you know something he's he's
just I reckon the crib checks had to go
work on a building site there's nothing
I'm working a building site when you
think of well but he's gone the other
way that guy who certainly is doing the
why're you coming fuss yeah someone
ought to take his place from the
entertainment world yeah we went and
thought who were we done with now big
shot was send him there send him back
send him send Shaq back ring why are you
coming fast man over Instagram yeah no
we're just wait wait Ian's been chained
shakin who's Ian I don't know your life
do you know why cuz you're my cameraman
one day a week I don't know hang up on
corn I go
I'm so annoyed by this little bit in the
video already
it's literally I fought last week's
districts were a bit annoying this is
night wow I mean that was a bar like a
MacBook Pros on him because I guarantee
you this guy has never seen the gun
that's a funny little fries for him yeah
he's just he's got a hangover this is
absolutely terrible
kondeh to reply he can't reply sorry
I've been away oh actually really
[__] video can you believe it I'm a
little bit proud right now
oh geez cameraman that is really good
there's a little thing that just made me
laugh there
it's the way he checks his own jacket
one thing that you gotta understand if
you really need a budget I can lend you
a pound so far that the tragedy of all
of these bar districts we watch this
yeah this is probably the best one in
terms of like entertainment yeah abscess
being entertaining yeah beef and veggie
now you wanna be's bredrin
no boy stop begging for attention the
old man stop acting crazy the hunt is a
very good actor he's it the eyes you see
the eyes crazy is good looking like a
disco aj Tracy you'd be watching me see
she was a little baby copy my style but
you still can't trace me that's actually
a decent ball nice actually that is
decent
this is obviously did or this isn't just
someone going I've got a rhyme I'm going
to rhyme more you are a bad man fam
oh geez cameraman do you not I hate
about this song I've heard it a couple
of times before because obviously we got
the inside scoop yeah it sticks in your
[__] head
that's what they call in Germany an
earworm it really pisses me off so like
that late last night I was trying to get
asleep and not like it here was like
this [__] song there's another
youtuber who thinks he can sing
Loren's responsible gabite Hannah she
she's the one on the YouTube rewind who
goes isn't it so great hope you can all
be so vulnerable and say what we really
feel what she means there is isn't it
great how we can package of on their
ability and sell it basically I'm
desperate no what should they've invited
our own genius to explain her the irony
genius can you imagine though if you
like kept every single person in your
life that has ever been there it would
be impossible you couldn't juggle it
what your friends from first grade
second grade third grade and then in
college in high school in every
relationship you've ever had that's how
she explains why she's got no friends
just keep in touch with me it would be
impossible to keep up with everyone
you've ever spoken to think about that
for a second all these people you never
spoken to you couldn't talk to them all
yeah can I just say you would probably
really like a jumper it looks like The
Lion King the nipples right naturally
people just fall out and sometimes it's
not a fight sometimes there's something
that happened you just kind of grow
apart and that's okay
but because of who I am it's really hard
for me to accept that over time you
should lose people do you know I mean
whenever that does happen in my head I'm
just like I hope you miss me I hope you
miss me hope you miss me
what about missing them no doesn't
happen I'm only gonna miss this is the
way that modern people operate do you
miss me no well I don't miss you [__]
no but if you go gym with me I make
extra few girls liability do you miss
this dick though link them to this video
right and say imagine Gaby Hannah is my
enormous [__] so that line people want
to talk when I'm not around to here
means a few things one is obviously like
gossip and rumors but a lot of it too is
when people can't just confront you
about a problem so very introspective
though is it it's all about blaming
everyone else this isn't it
about maybe I'm a [__] this is not wood
made for a good course maybe I'm a [__]
maybe I'm a loser I'm tougher than you
think but it also was supposed to be a
deeper meaning on DNA
sorry so where does this come from is
thinking on sort of a genetic level like
that you know the bonds between adenine
and the molecular structure of how your
body is made up yeah that's exactly yes
you've nailed it Neil deGrasse Tyson
invited arrived for cheese and wine
anyway I knew exactly what you were
doing walking away from me they're
afraid of me the whole world's about her
so she walks into Starbucks in the
morning she goes I'll have a latte
please
and the guy goes yeah okay fine she's
like why are you giving me attitude it's
like some [__] working in Starbucks
I'm having a bad day man I you put uh
I'm not a monster you can talk to me and
the guys like yeah I [__] know it
what's your name she's like just put
monster on the cup if you don't like me
[__] [__] I've never seen someone
trigger you discipline I just hate when
people make everything about them yeah
everything's about that person might as
she was talking about delivery drivers
friends they've always come and gone
they come that this whole song is the
most egotistical [__] genuinely it goes
Kanye West is thy comfort in that in the
sound of goodbye I mean is they're
really cool so what she's doing here
she's doing the pained Artie she's lying
though because they've literally ghost
at her she's even admitted that they
didn't say a goodbye they just stopped
replying
you're bullshitting yourself is she on
earth people after you text people ten
times after they've ghosts they're
people I guess this is goodbye then yeah
I hate that I guess we're not friends
and I hear but I mean it's like
literally if I'm not replying [__] off I
think the imagery for this song
can I just say her jumper completely
takes away from the serious nature of
her message I think the imagery of the
song is me tweaking my little nipples
speaking of youtubers who do music ksi
has a new summer
Cass I know pool of his own semen Oh 1g
huggy really needs clear though on this
is actually really good but the beat is
also really good yeah thank you agree
I'm still make my mind up I've made it
[Music]
okay I agree this is probably running
off on his best yeah it's good this is
good the beat is really one of my
favorite it's classic his favorite kinda
up is a I'm a like this I'm a table if
they don't like them and if they like
them they probably love it like it's
it's one of those that's decent you can
go either way depending on if you like
JJ but that's alright I think this is my
favorite mmm everyone's saying that I
was wrong about protector by the way in
the last video [__] them I don't care I
don't have to like anyone show me the
kids probably a nice lava I don't have
to like music is subjective it's what
y'all renew so if I don't like the sound
of his voice over but that's that's my
decision
in other news come believe I'm gonna say
this Randy Couture aka UFC legend like
the alan shearer
of the UFC like he was loved he's been
face time in a girl who's video recorded
it and uploaded it to the it and they're
eating his meat like i can't tell you
what what the [__] moment this is for
MMA like he is the granddaddy of Mme
yeah they call him captain america like
he does
support the troops like he is like the
good guy he wants he's like six foot two
he took on a six foot seven guy he
warned he's a hero he's thing to the UFC
funds america's change now american your
meat I'm really not looking forward to
watching it but I know it's something
that we have to do to none of me and
it's like love it's it's it's like Gary
Lineker beaten off like I was gonna
watch it Jeremy and just to see what the
hell's going on here okay there is he's
going for it it 55 he's still doing this
I feel like some middle-aged man about a
reawakening I'm thought I want to be
part of that generation I don't know
like I think 18 currently he went
through a lot of women back in the day
as well so maybe it's it's just like a
thing what did we rate in this penis
size shaves as balls by the way if
you're wondering Athena 455 shaving his
balls for 55 as mud he's showing them
his Botox do you think he squats
Lawrence no I don't do you think you
squat right now so some girl has clearly
FaceTime them and set him up big time
she is the one who we should be really
looking in disgust yeah I'd like to see
her face yeah I guess you conned old
Randy Rodney doesn't know anything about
the eyes close it's weird this isn't
this weird is gay we've got stalemate on
this Shore who keep coming about we have
to keep an eye on how things are going
we're gonna look at the Christian girls
we need to say how's the marriage going
alright are they in fact divorced yet
look at those eyes those are the kind of
eyes who killed next to you when she's
gonna suck on some dick
[Music]
you guys that we could never have before
complete that sentence can I just say
I'm hoping that they release a lubricant
that's made out of holy water chances
low this is completely brand-new Kristin
actually worked with some of our sisters
to design them you designed this this is
words on a jumper we've been working
tirelessly we'll find a font will any
literally this [__] Aziza shovel yeah I
mean just [__] them out
I'd really just held up t-shirt in front
of the girls eyes by accident when they
crush they cut just listening women if
my [__] edit later
shut up watch a face on the right oh
what a [__] goes up a book can I say the
one on the left now is incredible for an
exclamation of something so if the other
ones saying something would be like you
during the podcast going so the other
day I was thinking make a really good
point and I go yes during this Christmas
season how you can make Christmas more
meaningful more Christ centered more
Christ focus how can I make my Christmas
more Christ focus invite them round yeah
if he defines that's on him as long as
you sent in the Google invite you know
that you're good don't you know yeah
don't do it on Facebook cause I don't
think Jesus goes on there often I don't
see him active he's yeah it is fro
requests are full he's often away can I
just say I'm making fun of these people
right and I don't like them I don't like
these people but one thing I do like
there are some good lessons in the Bible
but like not lessons because it's the
Bible they're just good lessons so why
did they have to make it also for
bengali though well because it's Jesus
focus let's all just pull our Bibles out
and have a little read you probably got
one on your phone Brian just like I do
you know you're not gonna pull your
Bible up come on just pull the Bible app
out have you not download give me a
phone I'll download the Bible app I know
you want it
yet there's a Bible app you have to
prepare for it oh let me just check the
margin it wasn't free the bite has the
Bible the funny thing is it's actually
top here
it offers in-app purchase are you
[__] sue I think there's like a Jesus
AR thing in there as well there's like a
little game you can play holocron Jesus
racing and Jesus at the beginning of the
game pops up and goes it's Samia Jesus
this contest for the first time on this
show we may cover something to do with
brexit I want your opinion on this I
want your opinion on something you know
the whole thing that's been going on
Tereza made we don't get into that
basically everyone has different ideas
what rights it should be blah blah blah
brexit may not happen may happen we
aren't expressing our personal interest
but an MP tweeting I want to know if you
think MP should be tweeting this sort of
thing this is how angry I am shaking
with rage after an utterly rubbish
response from the PM angry face she then
claims she's shaking so badly
literally film in a hand for two seconds
have you ever been so angry that you've
been shaking with this hand but your
other hand has been perfectly stable
able to film it why not voice your
opinion on a turn the camera round
pointed at your mouth yeah and say what
the [__] has gone through your head if
you're outraged call her on it
why are you out ridge what is she doing
wrong exactly you're an MP keep your
head this is a robot or is it Russia
showed a robot at a conference this was
called robot Boris and he was praised
for being incredible by the state media
turns out Boris is just a man in a suit
I would love to heal what cruft this
saying about like the technology that
went into making on yeah I would love
that
some of you has started questioning the
robot's movements because he was moving
so much like a human that's the picture
of the guy backstage allegedly it made
me that someone's causing a hoax here
but it just proves on the moon London's
were [__] they'd do this no problem
certainly they don't care as long as you
think that they've got the best
technology in the world and that they're
leading the way they don't give a [__]
if you actually leading the way or not
yeah it's about looking the part exactly
to back your government because they
don't care about robotics so they know
that they're doing well behind the
scenes anyway they don't want to show
the enemy hope they've got just how your
man in a [__] suit yeah Brian space
travel
yeah it was possible here's your Van
Alen radio belt mate how's
around Earth now a [__] I flush
doesn't it looks pretty flat now that
was what worried me as well
this is Virgin Galactic yes I go to
space Richard Branson book you know this
walk before you can run model yeah sort
the [__] trains out before you try to
take us to [__] space all the planes
the planes are transmitted honestly in
common sort the [__] trains are right
yeah honestly are you saying I'm saying
sort them out because getting from
Newcastle or London yeah is a [__]
bawling oh I want to say this honestly
this and this youtuber Rachel literally
picks apart two blog posts that girl
defined wrote about homosexuality and
gay marriage and basically how awful and
disgusting it is we uncovered like the
hick is very religious maybe they don't
hate what religion doesn't like what
religion loves the game Jeremy it
doesn't it just generally doesn't go
hand-in-hand
which is ironic because kids tend to
yeah what good for them right gay people
tend to like holding hands more than
straight people I swear straight people
hold hands just as much as dick right
Wow you're showing unity with the gay
community yes I am unity with the game I
love the gifts the gays it's the fact
you save the gays the Muslim question
whether human alcohol of their game what
some are gonna call them I don't know
it's not like they have some sort of
popular title that they love to say that
all the letters isn't it btq yeah cute
for queer I didn't like that they who's
they but the gays the gays don't like
what q queer I didn't go to the case
there's a really what's up with AK
useful what else do you think it's for
what questions Queen Queens ago there
are some real Queens out then
[Music]
no escape from the girl to finds open
your eyes anus food reviewer I do
reviews on the YouTube you never knew
such a cool dude I keep it so flat and
do you know why it's better to buy their
food I love him as I've never done that
no no rewind ready can I get a rewind he
is in such a good mood look at the point
double point as double appointment he's
like Woody from Toy Story so this
particular so what it is it's so it's I
love 63,000 views the last in or that
does look good full of purple that looks
really good it makes me want a pepperoni
pizzas ramen oh shoot but it looked
really Betty
laudable red-blooded Oh so let's go and
try it how many bites before we got a
comment over them AHA that's a three by
that's a three by our room one I'm gonna
put it this way I feel like it's because
the cheese was too stringy though right
he's going for it let's business you
want more people add more your [__]
I need to gift this up for when someone
asked me a question on Twitter and I've
got no [__] clue what the answer is
just right here right it came out to
like very soft very flaky very good the
bottom is all done he almost looks like
if you ever seen the Great British Bake
Off when they go he's got exactly that
face oh he would be a perfect judge for
that he'd be incredibly has he already
been eaten see around his top lip there
this some like tomorrow's stains can you
see that and it looks like there's a
dinner medal if you just look there if
you look here above the lips there seems
to be where he's chewed on something
previously nice so pure guys so cure do
you know what I mean
[Music]
the Blue Bunny strawberry crunches are
you ready are you ready for this hype no
were there to buy that strawberry bunny
crunch bar play mine crying Mike wizard
oh he's got a server on minecraft I I
got my hopes up because I thought maybe
he's got a Minecraft each other yes yes
it's got a Minecraft shadow
Oh tell me this doesn't mean shut down
big videos please tell me this videos
videos right channel my video so we're
doing that um you can see reason
different texture pack are using aspects
as facts obviously that I just started
today I saw a yogscast video so i'm like
no this game throws these discs on
cently having an absolute [__] on I just
so badly wanted to be part of like XO
amazing subscribe
wow really gone in on this
someone's Skype for me so spec to say
this minecraft channel was a little bit
over [__] sure a boring channel let's
finish off on a on a good food review
yes look like a chocolate-covered
doughnuts or the blueberry let's call
the Bluebird
I'm literally changing my [__]
Twitter logo 21st bytes that you see it
discovered out to make dinosaurs let's
go fund me going fly him to the UK we'll
take him to all UK restaurant that was
truly I don't think really he's part of
the news we just want to watch him he
feels like he's part the news he's a
good little roundup guy so if you want
us to watch anything else talk about
anything else hit that subscribe button
like the video leave a comment let us
know
we're gonna go have pizza play minecraft
than any ice cream we're gonna it's a
food review I find to do and if just do
everything of us
seriously I cheers father see is